hey what's up guys my name is trying to
welcome back to my game engine series
sir over the last few weeks of course my
life has been hectic as always I'm
getting married in two weeks but if you
don't know I'm really excited to sit
down and have some time to spend on
hazel once again and I can't wait for
kind of all of this stuff that's going
on in my life to kind of just be over so
that I can just kind of get back to just
having a normal peaceful life but anyway
anyway let's just kind of move on and
talk about hazel because what I did
before this episode is though it's
completely unplanned no this is planned
I know roughly what I'm going to do just
because I've thought about it but
there's no nothing's planned so it's
gonna have a nice live episode because
you guys seem to love dat you guys seem
to not like when I plan things and then
just copy and paste in code I actually
don't even know what kind of what I
write today we're gonna see how we go
we're gonna talk about some stuff it's
almost gonna be like a good
old-fashioned kind of churner episode
first thing I want to do as always is
just thank the people who made this
possible patient I'm hopeful slash the
chatter is a way for you guys to support
me and make sure that I can keep making
these videos especially at a time like
this a huge thank you to everyone who's
making this stuff possible today we're
gonna just talk about what is going on
with hazel we're gonna start on the
renderer and the whole rendering side of
things and we're just gonna talk about
like there's a bunch of things going on
in hazel architectural II that I have
kind of been ignoring for a while and in
fact I'm even not hunterson sure that a
clean check out of the repository
actually will build so there's just a
lot of things going on so but it's gonna
kind of talk about a lot of things today
and where this is gonna kind of go as
well as get a start on the renderer so
this video will probably be titled
something like you know rendering OpenGL
rendering context and swap chain or
something like that I don't know but
we'll kind of just talk about things as
well so first step is to take a look at
the state of everything so let's just go
ahead and take a look at what I saw what
I have been tasting alright so I think
what I actually did and what I kind of
forgot about it in a sense if we just
take a look at this errorless I just did
a clean build I think of everything and
we have this so we have a lot of
warnings and we have three linking
errors because I actually completely
forgot I went on to describing the
renderer with the introduction to
rendering video as well as um
the actual kind of rendering API
architecture video but but before that
what I did was I actually gave you guys
a question as to how do we fix these I'm
going linking errors that we have over
here right and then I proceeded to
completely forget about that stuff
because of course my life is just a huge
mess right now but anyway not that it's
a bad mess but it's just it's just it's
very hard to do a lot of things at once
that's all anyway so we have this kind
of linking errors and I asked you guys
why are we having them because
essentially what's happening and I gave
you guys the question of how do we fix
this stuff what's happening here is that
if we look at kind of the just a build
architecture of all these modules that
we have here what's happening is I am
GUI is being built as a static library
right filiz go to properties over here
and we take a look at where are we just
this configuration type it's such a
static library of course and we did that
in pre Meg what that means is that it's
building statically right so we're
building a static library out of all of
the I'm going code which is great right
but then what's happening is being
linked into hazel hazel is a dll file
right which means that blinking actually
occurs right dll files are very much
like Exe files in the sense that they
just kind of well they have like every
points and all of that but in this sense
they link the actual the actual library
into like libraries actually get linked
into this dll file and everything has to
be resolved at linked time right so
that's great
because it means that any usage of I am
gooey inside hazel will just be resolved
in the linker willing called functions
and that's great but the issue comes
from sandbox when we decide to actually
um use I'm GUI functions in sandbox by
just linking what we linked which is
well it's actually not even this stuff
that's in the additional dependencies is
just stuff that we've actually linked
into into the linker which in this case
is just like simple post and alive
really libraries and also Visual Studio
kind of like warm Microsoft Windows kind
of libraries you know like kennel 32 and
here's the 32 that kind of stuff but if
we look at references you can see it
as hazel that's where the linking is
happening so sandbox didn't exe the
links this hazel dll file problem is if
we use something like I'm glue begin in
an end
inside sandbox right however that hasn't
been used ever inside hazel well guess
what happens when hazel links I am GUI
it does not link those symbols right
because why cuz they're not used right
to the dead
why on earth would they include those
functions in this binary if they're not
used it doesn't do that but because of
that it means that they're not exposed
to sandbox so what is the way of fixing
this well there's several ways we could
fix this right we could like one way
literally is just like oh look I'm going
to begin well you know if we were to go
into hazel I am GUI sorry event the
hazel sauce
you know I'm Billy Leia or whatever and
I don't know just use like begin let's
just use begin and end right if I do a
build again or all of this stuff okay so
that didn't work and that's probably
because I don't think any I'm doing
symbols are actually being exported at
this rate I'm doing API is kind of what
we need and that's probably not set
correctly at all I don't know if it's
worth exploring this because it's just a
temporary solution but if we take a look
at perhaps hazel Vanda I am GUI and in
the pre Meg file I think we'll find that
yeah like it's not defined at all
whereas we should probably define I'm
GUI the I'm GUI by here to be let me
just find something and for example I'm
going a PR should probably be defined to
DLL export so let's go ahead and again I
don't really want to do this but I'll do
this just quickly to demonstrate my
point so let's define I'm going API as
no in fact let's just do it in this just
because it is it just because it is
legends demo video so we'll define I'm
doing API to be decals BEC DLL export we
will build I'm GUI and hazel right and
then what we'll do is we'll take away
that decals back deal I'll export which
actually might trigger a rebuild now
that I think about
really stupid yes it did nevermind
that's not gonna work so instead how
about we do it a bit better
and inside the I'm GUI build function
when we actually include this stuff
which we don't actually include
everything anyway there's no real way
around this let's just do it properly I
was gonna hack my way through this but
clearly that's just not great so what
I'll do quickly here is for hazel
inside the preprocessor I'll just set
I'm going AP I equal to Dec whole spec
DLL export like that alright and then
inside I'm GUI I guess I'll do the same
and then inside sandbox I'll set it to
import alright this is just a little
quick hack and then hopefully this now
should actually resolve those symbols
because they've been used so let's take
a look at that okay so we get a we get a
successful build here right all that's
kind of been resolved so that's what you
can do you can just kind of for with
that but again the problem is that if we
don't actually use the symbols right so
I don't know I'll try and remove this
I'm not sure if it it like it might work
in this situation it depends if they've
been used before like yeah so that built
but if we maybe try and use something
like I am GUI you know color edit for or
something you know let's just try and do
something like that just to hack it in
then that might ultimately not link okay
it does link great everything's the
worst at this point everything just
works everything works but it's not
supposed to work anyway my point again
being that certain symbols might not get
completely forwarded but that is a
solution what I've just shown you is a
solution you can just kind of make sure
that they're actually used somewhere and
then do a deck deck inspect DLL export
import as requires that you actually get
to use those symbols right in the way
that I showed you that's totally
possible in a fight if we just run this
I don't know what out goal will sit just
to have a window that says hello world I
guess and there it is right and we can
drag it out which is pretty cool okay so
there we have that window you
that is a solution another solution and
I just want to reiterate the problem I
know this is supposed to be a rendering
video but maybe we've gone a little bit
off the rails because this is completely
unplanned anyway um another thing that
you could do and the board would
probably be the better solution long
term because again visualize the problem
we have again is that I'm Google's
aesthetic library into a DLL file but
the DLL file has the power to strip
everything that's unused
from I'm GUI so if the exe file which
links the DLL file which has a static
lip in it if that decides to use
something that is not present there will
get a linking error ideally what you
would do is make sure that everything
from i''m GUI is exported into the DLL
file but how do you do that without
actually using those functions or making
sure that they're used
the answer is basically to use a module
file a module definition file ifs above
def file dot BEF right what are you
doing there is you list all the function
signatures that you want to export and
that is what the DLL will export um if
we take a look at hazel really quickly I
don't even know where this is because I
think it's an input yeah we have a
module definition file so we could make
like a hazel of death file essentially
which just has all of the functions that
want to export from I'm glist it what
that means is that everything that hazel
links in from I am GUI that is inside
this definition file it will also
actually include in our binary and
market for export so that we can import
it inside sandbox and that will fix the
problem
unfortunately these def files are not
easy to make like you have to make them
manually there's as far as I know
there's no tools to do them and I
believe I actually have one of them if
we take a look really quickly a little
sneak preview for non patrons we just
duck jump into the hazel dev repository
and take a look at hazel you can see I
actually made a definition file here so
we have a hazel dot def file which has
like you know showed a moment window
beginning and Colette it for that kind
of stuff right and you can see that we
have library hazel and it exports the
following options and that's how we can
actually propagate them into our sandbox
projects so this is a pain because you
have to get the signature right and then
every
you have all the functions manually so
it sucks to be honest I hate it
which is why I've kind of been having a
discussion with all the people on the
patron channel which is the hazel dev
Channel kind of been having a discussion
as to maybe we should convert hazel into
a static library because DLL files are
great but they also to be honest I don't
like DLL files the reason I wanted to
make a little DLL originally is because
of maybe the possibility of cots locking
code and and also just to make
client-side kind of linking easier
meaning that if we make a game with
hazel which in this case is sandbox
right the only thing we have to link is
hazel because hazel is at the ll file
which contains everything else that has
a benefit obviously but it also has the
drawback well well first of all that
benefit is easily fixed because we're
using pre make s our build system so
there's no reason why we can't generate
a game kind of pre make file which
actually links everything that's needed
anyway and in my opinion whenever I'd be
what making a game with hazel I would
want a visual studio solution with
everything in it anyway right so the
fact that we only have to link one thing
into the game isn't actually that big of
a deal because again we'll have the pre
make file already set up every time we
create a new project which links
everything anyway benefits of static
libraries of course essentially that
everything just gets linked into the dot
exe file at Build time which means
everything is kind of the right version
everything's up-to-date the C++ standard
library we have one version of that
which we do not need to dynamically link
like we are right now there's speed
benefits for static linking right
meaning that because the linker is aware
of all the symbols coming in it can
actually do optimizations like inlining
which is impossible with the DLL file
because it's a separate module we also
have benefits such as what we don't need
dll files floating around we just have
one exe file and that's our entire game
that's it an ideal else what else is
there just sort of my head
we don't need stupid export import
macros and all like if we look at just
how many warnings we have I'll just do a
quick revealed while I'm talking if we
have a look at all these more
we have half of them are just really
annoying and because of DLL boundaries
you know like this for example so how to
stop this here you know and I minced it
where is it
you know this shared pointer needs to
have DLL interface to be used by clients
that's a really annoying error which you
basically can't really fix because we're
using shed pointers across DLL
boundaries right that's really annoying
templates also sometimes suffer so
there's a lot of like really important I
mean a lot of really annoying errors
that we have by DLL so to be honest at
the way I'm learning right now is I
might just want to nuke this and just go
with it sometime man I've been talking
so long I might just want to nuke that
and go with the static libraries right
that's kind of the idea so I think that
that's what I'll do let me know what
your thoughts are regarding converting
hazel to a static library in the
comments there is obviously the
possibility of supporting both so if you
want to build it as a DLL you can if you
wanna build as a static library you can
the more I think about it the less
interest I have in supporting both ways
I believe that especially for a project
like hazel which has worked on primarily
by just me right supporting too much and
supporting a very flexible build style
or workflow is just gonna be a pain to
maintain and I don't think it's healthy
I think that it's better for hazel for
us as a group to define a good set of
like things to follow for hazel right
meaning that you know let's define the
way that you build games and hazel right
how do you build them while you use a
static library in this case right you
kind of have an actual pipeline of
workflow that's really well-defined and
really robust and then people will
follow that you know there's flexibility
garbage is why I like unity and unreal
sometimes are really not good engines
for certain specific tasks they're just
generalist engines which do everything
really well which is great and really
flexible and easy to work with but I
don't want that in hazel I guess because
like we can't build a big generalist
engine doesn't I mean I don't have a
team of a thousand people working on
this right we can't build an engine that
big so what we should do I think is just
have a really tight workflow which again
for some people might analyze some
people but hopefully will try to just
like define and decide on something
sounds
well here and then that way everything
will be just kind of really clean and
really easy and will really work well
but we don't have to and it'll be really
simple probably as well because it does
not like a thousand different code paths
for the same thing depending on how you
want to do this or that right I don't
like that it's not gonna work out well
for hazel I know it so that's what I
want to do this in a certain way and in
this case I'm thinking maybe we just say
hazel is gonna build a static library
it's gonna simplify so many things it's
gonna mean that yes everything is kind
of a build time but that's fine because
the thing is there's no reason really to
have hazel hot-swappable if you look at
like it it's software's kind of model
that they do for a lot of games like
doom where they kind of autumn through
at least what they had and actually they
do it for most of their engine games but
they have the game actually being built
as a dll and then the engine loads that
dll and that's again that's really
useful and that's really nice because it
means that your deal you know the game
is a dll file which you can again Ryan
and hot-swap and do whatever you want
with and then the engine deals like why
would you want the engine to be hot
swappable that is mimicking that does
that doesn't make any sense because
ideally you're using this engine to make
a game or an application so the engine's
done the engines ready you're not just
modifying engine code all the time what
are you modifying your game code or your
application code that's the part that
you want a hot swap so this design is
not really beneficial anyway something
beneficial for engine development not
for actually using the engine which is
what we want to think about long term
obviously that's like a long term kind
of strategy so that's an important point
I think as well then the other thing is
that we're gonna have scripting we have
100% gonna have scripting there's no way
this engines not gonna have scripting
it's not gonna mean say plus allows
everything right so because of that
obviously the scripts are gonna be live
live editable and live possible easy
right that's fine that's that's implied
this kind of stuff sable cost code I
don't think we should put any effort
into making sure that that's hospitable
because it's just not necessary so
that's kind of the idea um what else do
I want to say yes it's gonna solve a lot
of errors it's gonna mean that we don't
have to deal with DLL boundary issues or
the different versions of the C++
library potentially causing really
annoying errors it's means that we don't
have
export/import things I don't know static
libraries are just really nice to work
with because they just work right then
they contain the symbols they need and
then at the end and to enter the exe
file into your actual final product
that's where everything gets pulled in
and linked which gives you just faster
performance at runtime as well sorry
it's hard to kind of for me right now
having thought about this for several
weeks it's really hard for me to justify
actually using dll's if we had like a
level editor that was written in c-sharp
for example hypothetically and that was
written in WPF or something like that
yeah which probably we would have to use
a DLL there's nowhere on that but I have
no plans to that as I said the level
editor and all the game engine tools are
gonna be written natively right using
I'm GUI at this stage although it
doesn't matter what UI system we use the
point is they're gonna be written as
games essentially right they're gonna be
written as real-time runtime
applications which is gonna be again the
best and fought and most fast way like
the fastest way to actually write these
tools in my situation because I don't
come a team and that's also gonna have
that added benefit of being
cross-platform right a WPF isn't
cross-platform is Windows only obviously
we could use QT but there's no way I
want to use QT to be honest we're gonna
write everything I'm going everything's
runtime everything's kind of ready to go
on all platforms including like phones
or whatever we choose to support and
hazel I think it's gonna be the best
strategy for sure and we definitely
don't need a DLL for that to actually
work we just need like static libraries
will be fine and in fact even better as
far as I can see so that's my plan
hopefully you guys can get on board with
that but let me know what like I mean
not even if I'm missing something really
big annual stress so I might just get
this place if you guys have anything if
I've missed something big or you guys
think that we'll hang on what are you
doing why you do ELLs are better you
know do that leave a comment below
right this is a discussion and I really
want to hear your opinion on what we
actually should do but if we do decide
to go with static libraries which I
think we should we should probably get
that done in the neck
episode you like that sound we should
definitely do that in the next episode
because if we can get that stuff done
we're about to make a lot of different
API classes and stuff like that for
rendering so instead of having to
sprinkle everything with hazel API we
can get rid of that entirely if we
choose to go with with the static
library thing so we'll probably do that
next episode so I'll wait a few days
before I make the next episode just to
see your response to this but I think
that's the direction we're going to go
in and then the episode after that we're
gonna I guess sat on the renderer um and
kind of deal with that so and then I
might make a if you guys are interested
in that module definition file I think I
might make in the future I've already
written it down I will make a simple
sloth series video which covers that um
and then you can kind of go that route
you personally if you kind of choose to
anyway I'm sorry that we didn't get to
rendering this time but I'm glad that we
talked about this stuff because like um
in fact if we just jump in here cuz I
didn't even address everything we jump
in here for a second um and we take a
look at you know we've got no arrows
anymore because so many warnings right
half the stuff is because of DLL issues
half the stuff like Seiya like you know
this stuff being unsafe is because we
were using deprecated functions but
again this is an ass sighs I'm going I
would probably use s can s sscanf
underscore s which just provides a size
for the buffer you're scouting into just
so that you don't have a flow it and
that's a really easy thing to do but
again since that's not my code what
we'll do is just build my own GUI or
build whatever we need with this CIT
secure no warnings macro defined in the
Premack file a DLL stuff and then this
stuff is just stuff that's in the pre
make file that should not be in the pre
make file so there's a lot of
maintenance stuff that we will do and
potentially again because I am getting
married in two weeks and I am crazy busy
because I'm still working full time
although I did take the week before the
wedding off as well just so I can like
you know just come back into reality and
just not be running around everywhere
and be stress for my wedding because of
the wedding and everything is going
right now I think that maybe we can just
take it easy and that way I could still
give you guys an episode every week but
it might be able to be tamer and we
might just take this time to just clean
stuff up but that being said like I'm
ready to make the rendering episodes as
well I want to make the content ring the
first thing we'll do I kind of just made
a plan this morning is what we're gonna
do is we're gonna start off by creating
like a rendering context and swap
chained kind of freakin jail right and
eventually obviously when we support
other api's they will have those classes
as well so once we have that we can
probably move on to creating I want to
probably start off with creating a very
basic shade a compilation file just that
we can really easily just create shaders
because that's gonna be important and
then that way as we build stuff we'll
still be able to have stuff on the
screen because we can always write
OpenGL client-side when we need to right
and then we'll kind of just you know
that way we have something on the screen
every episode it's not like hey here's
five episodes of rendering stuff and
then at the end we'll see a triangle no
because that's kind of how it usually
goes well we'll always see a triangle
and then we'll kind of slowly pull that
card away into classes and into like
into our actual rendering API and into
our end row so that's my plan with that
hope you guys enjoyed this video if you
did you can hit the like button let me
know your thoughts about all this again
you know it's really frustrating for me
to be honest to just not kind of move on
and build a surrenderer but again like
you have to understand I'm going through
a period in my life right now where I
just cannot like just do as much as I
want to without going insane
so I would rather just offset this like
another month essentially or just like
just kind of you know again be a bit
cruzi over this next month and then hit
it hard after everything settles down
and just that's when we'll do it and I
think that'll be a lot better than just
kind of going full speed ahead into
rendering right now and then having to
take a break because obviously I will be
going away I'm like a honeymoon and all
that stuff so yes you can also have a
helps both serial of patriarchal visage
the cherry peach thank you to everyone
who makes this series possible if you
can't wait for me to do all this cleanup
card and you want to just get this stuff
as soon as possible support me on
patreon
you'll get access to the github
repository for the development branch of
hazel which already has like an OpenGL
renderer written basically it's not like
complete you don't want to see like PBR
shading yet but it is a lot more mature
there's like a render a command Q that's
written everything which encodes
rendering commands into like a command
buffer and then execute them tab time a
different thread all that kind of stuff
is already there so if you can't wait
check that out otherwise see how much
you can do I guess of this by yourself
all this cleanup qui that I've mentioned
a really good kind of homework task for
you guys convert hazel into a static
library see how you'd see how you go
with that because there are a few kind
of little small things that you will
have to tweak and see if you can get
hazel building with zero warnings that's
your challenge I will see you next time
good bye
[Music]
you
[Music]